hi this is James Franco and I'm here
with film courage calm I'm talking to
Karen worden and David Brannon we're
gonna talk about this Palo Alto story's
campaign on IndieGoGo thank you so much
for listening
James when you were writing your book
Palo Alto were you thinking that one day
you would eventually turn it into a
feature film or several feature films I
I mean I've been in the film business
for 16 or 17 years now so making
adapting it into a movie was just
something that I automatically thought
about but it very very quickly I
realized that I have one other people to
adapt it I
I love the adaptation process and most
of the movies that are practiced at
tations of novels and poetry in some
cases so I love the adaptation process
but I I wanted other people to do it
because if I did my own book it would
you know be different because it would
be in a different form it was a good
film but it would be just me mediating
you know one more time and giving my
version of the theory and said if I
brought in other people they would add
to the material it would give their you
know they would put their own spin on
certain things and it would be mediated
through them and so my hope was that is
that it will retain something of the
spirit of my book but then will also
gain because it will you know be taken
into directions that I that I never
would have taken it if I didn't and
according to the IndieGoGo you're slated
to start filming in actually in Palo
Alto in August
is that right do you have special
locations already picked out
yeah there have been you know series of
scouts out there I mean I obviously I
know the area really well but a lot of
the others have gone out you know and my
mother and others are taking them around
and it's a location